recently on twitter people have been
telling jokes or making jokes about the
joke that they would make which is
rather meta and people have been doing
this about all sorts of topics and
philosophy
and philosophers are
one of those sets of topics so i thought
i would do a roundup of what i consider
to be
the best ones now obviously humor is
very subjective so you might not see
these as the best ones yourself but
you're welcome to put other ones in the
comments on this video or in twitter as
well that's where all these are coming
from
so this is probably the most meta of the
jokes that are out there about this
because it's jokes about jokes and about
the trolley problem
there are five jokes about a manual tied
to one track and one joke about jon
stewart mill tied to another track and a
joke about philip a foot is running
downhill out of control fortunately
you're standing next to a lever which
when thrown will redirect now notice
that this is a trivial trolley problem
is it not because what happens if
philippa foote runs over jokes about
emmanuel kant or jokes about jon stewart
mill obviously people aren't hurt
but you never know so let's move on to
the
litany of
jokes
here we have the pre-socratics
i had a joke about heraclitus but now
it's gone followed by i had to joke
about permanentes just the one those are
the two that are often counterposed to
each other heraclitus obviously being
the person who although he believes in a
logo says that everything is in flux
parmenides saying there isn't everything
in flux there's just the one thing and
it doesn't flux at all it doesn't change
it just is
then we have his uh disciple xeno i know
a joke about zeno but if i start i never
get to the end zeno had the paradoxes of
motion for example the archer or the
achilles and the tortoise and then we
have i have i have a joke about
protagoras but it's only relatively
funny protagoras famously said human
being is the measure of all things
endorsing perhaps a certain kind of
relativism
then we get socrates and plato's mixed
in here of course
i have a joke about socrates but it's
questionable i get that one right he's
always asking questions and then we see
him doing this afterwards me i have a
joke about plato and then socrates
what's a joke
i have a joke about socrates but plato
tells it better well this is alluding to
the so-called socratic problem
how much of what we're getting about
socrates is actually straight out of
plato and then finally here's the sort
of way plato depicts socrates ah my
friend you say you have a joke about
plato to tell a joke you must understand
what it means to be funny please explain
it to me i am ignorant of such things
and which wish to be enriched by your
knowledge
moving on to plato himself here's a
couple jokes about ideals and things
that are perfect i thought of a joke
about plato if i told it to you it'd be
a shadow of its true form i have a plato
joke i can only tell it under ideal
circumstances i know a joke about plato
and it's perfect and then we have
another good one i have a joke about
plato but it's spurious what is that
referring to some of the platonic
dialogues
are perhaps not written by plato and
then we have i could tell a joke about
plato but nobody in this cave with me
would get it not bad
here's some about aristotle
i have a joke about aristotle and it's
golden but mean
there's a terrible pun right
i have a joke about aristotle that i
have to practice until it's excellent as
if well you know aristotle actually does
talk about joking eutrophileia
as a virtue
then the last one i have a joke about
aristotle but it's lost as are many of
aristotle's texts
then we have cicero these are kind of
rough
i had a joke about cicero a bit
difficult to understand because only at
the end of a very long sentence with
lots of clauses and anecdotes like one
about a random patrician going to fish
markets 200 years before the joke the
verb i put it was
cicero writes very
longish paragraphs and
here's the next one i have a joke about
cicero but it'll take a few hours to
finish and then finally i had a joke
about cicero but i haven't found the
verb yet
moving on epictetus
the stoic philosopher i have a joke
about epictetus but i'm trying not to
feel too strongly about it i have a bad
epictetus joke but you probably wouldn't
mind either way
and then this is a
rough one i had a joke about epictetus
but it was kinda lame if you don't know
epictetus himself the great stoic
philosopher born a slave was lamed by
his owner before being freed
moving on to the medievals here's some
early to mid medieval right i have a
joke about saint augustine but now you
ask me i can't remember what it is i
used to tell a joke about augustine but
i stole it from a neighbor two
really great references to augustine's
confessions i leave it to you to read
the text and look them up the next two
are about boethius
if it is any consolation i have a joke
about boethius obviously consolation of
philosophy in which the other joke fits
in i have a boethius joke but it's still
spinning between good and bad spinning
on the wheel of fortune then we have
some anselm jokes obviously coming from
the pro slogian ii i have a joke about
saint anselm but you couldn't conceive
of it i have a joke about anselm which
is proof that a greater joke exists so
they're not getting anselm wrong on that
which is nice
then we have uh some peter abellard ones
there were quite a few of these
got a joke about peter abelard but it's
annoying as [ __ ] goes on forever
i have a joke about peter abelard it's
by far the most intelligent joke of all
of 12th century paris now abelard was
pretty famous for
[Music]
not just long-windedness but thinking he
was the smartest guy around here's
another one do i have a good joke about
peter abelard well yes and no seek at
known right his famous treatise
now here's another one that's even worse
than the one about epictetus and
lameness i have a joke about peter
abellard but i don't have the balls to
tell it
abelard was famously castrated
for his love affair with eloise
then we've got some about aquinas and
ockham i have a joke about aquinas but
i'm not sure if it's a philosophical or
a theological one it produces that
distinction and thomas have been arguing
about where the boundaries are ever
since
i used to tell the joke about aquinas
and it worked some of the time
somatiologia some are contra gentiles
well you win somewhere you lose summer
this is a thomas aquinas joke and then
ockham what are they going to joke about
occam's razor obviously i have a joke
about arkham but it's pretty simple and
then we have i had a joke about occam's
razor but it was needlessly complicated
we move on into the early modern period
with some descartes jokes i have a joke
about descartes but i don't remember it
clearly and distinctly
clear and distinct ideas are descartes
criterion for genuine knowledge
i think i have a joke about descartes
therefore i am a joke about descartes
now this is very funny because obviously
kids take heart
rate but in a certain way
thinking about a joke is definitely
within the realm of thought and the
mirth or humor that results from it is
also a thought for descartes
also have a good one about descartes but
i don't want to keep waxing on that's
referring to meditations too right and
the next one i have a joke about
descartes but it's really two jokes
referring to the dualism
between substances of mind and extended
substance and then finally hairy
turtledove uh the the great sci-fi
author weighs in i have a joke by
descartes dog i eats therefore i am's oh
that's a terrible one right ams is a
type of dog food
a lot of things about spinoza and then a
few about other moderns as well
i have a spinoza joke but it might
create bad optics not bad not bad but to
be fair none of these are funny i think
some of them are funny but yeah i get
the optics he was a lens grinder i have
a joke about spinoza but it has no
substance i mean the joke there
obviously is that's all spinoza talks
about
i have a joke about spinoza but it's
purposeless spinoza famously rejected
purposes or final causes and then this
is very low-hanging fruit i had a joke
about thomas hobbs it was nasty british
and short doesn't mention the joke i
have a joke about bishop berkeley and he
doesn't see it
there you know barkley was the idealist
who said to to be is to be perceived
seeing is a type of that and then
finally i have a savage joke about
rousseau but it's ignoble rousseau
thought the savages were
fairly noble right
next we have some hume jokes i have a
joke about david hume people always
laugh when i tell it but i can't be sure
it's funny he's got another one
i've a joke about hume but i don't know
if it will cause you to laugh hume uh
you know very famously
attacked or critiqued the idea that we
have
causality is something that we perceive
and uh so you know we can never truly be
sure about things that way right
um
what else do we have from from human
i've got a joke about hume in my head
but do i have it hume said that the self
was merely a bundle
of ideas and impressions so that there
really is no self and then finally
i have a joke about hume but it doesn't
consist of abstract reasoning concerning
quantity or number nor experimental
reasoning concerning matter of fact or
existence so what do you have to do with
it consign it to the flames right so
that's one of the problems with hume's
philosophy
we move on to emanuel kant i have a joke
about kant and it's very enlightening
okay kant you know what is enlightenment
uh i have a joke about kant but it's too
much a thing in itself the ding and zeke
i have a joke about kant but telling it
would not be acting in accordance with a
maxim which i could will to be a
universal law
first formulation of the categorical
imperative and then another one
referring to that i have a joke about
kant but unconditional laughter is not
guaranteed for all listeners which would
not necessarily be a reason not to tell
the joke
i've got a few hegel ones here
i heard a joke about hegel but i didn't
get it
referring to hegel's difficulty i can
tell you a joke about hegel if you're
not in good spirits right phenomenology
of spirit or geist
also translated as mind and then finally
i have a joke about hegel and marx but
you'll need to stand on your head to get
it marx famously turns hegel's whatever
we want to call it
system ideas approach method on its head
transmuting it from
idealism into materialism
i've got some kierkegaard jokes here i
thought of a joke about soren
kierkegaard but if i told it it would no
longer be a transcendent act of faith
for you to believe the joke exists and
then along the same lines i have a joke
about kierkegaard but it is quite a leap
finally i have a joke about kierkegaard
but whether i tell it or not i'll regret
it either way referring to either or
uh then we've got some schopenhauer
jokes and actually these are some of
these are kind of good i have a joke
about schopenhauer but i'm afraid it's
rather depressing okay that's
low-hanging fruit i would tell a joke
about schopenhauer but i just don't have
the will that's even better
it happened to me i made a schopenhauer
joke and nobody laughed more pessimism
and then we've got this one referring
back to hegel i mean i would do a
schopenhauer stand-up show but i'm sure
only five people would show up and the
show would get cancelled apparently
hegel jokes are more popular that's
referring to schopenhauer lining himself
up against the very popular hegel and
being sorely disappointed in the process
jon stewart mill
great utilitarian philosopher among
other things i have a jon stewart mill
joke but i'm not sure i see the utility
in it anymore that's pretty good i have
a jon stewart mill joke but it won't
tell it for the greater good again
utilitarianism and then we've got
another one i have a jon stewart mill
joke i'm confident the majority of you
will enjoy and then we have a reference
to on liberty and the harm principle i
have a joke on jon stewart mill but it
might harm you so we can't harm people
right
some good nietzsche jokes
i have a joke about nietzsche but only a
few free spirits will grasp it that's
sort of nietzsche interpretation
in a nutshell i would tell a joke about
nietzsche but it's abyssal nietzsche
famously talks about staring into the
abyss
i've got a joke about nietzsche that's
so good i could go on repeating it
forever
okay reference to
eternal recurrence of the same
i have the nietzsche joke but i haven't
the will to tell it similar to
schopenhauer but both of them do talk
about will quite a bit and then finally
somebody who probably didn't quite get
it i think he's actually
being a straight man the serious guy
about this these nietzsche jokes are
disgraceful to such a serious superior
type person study the books as far as
you can and you will find incomparable
treasures it's always it's always funny
to see people not getting a joke right
and so that's the best joke of all
except for
this one
which we're going to end on
i have a renaissance humanism joke but
the scholars are still feuding over
whether it really came from plato
aristotle epictetus or pliny
that's you know
if you know anything about about
renaissance scholarship and humanism
you'll get that one there could be many
others that would be telling that so
that's it for the jokes like i said you
know humor is a little s
subjective you may not think these are
quite so funny maybe in and explaining
them i've made them less funny or maybe
i made them more funny i don't really
know but i got a kick out of this and i
hope you do too
you